[GOOGLE THEME MUSIC]
MALE SPEAKER: Are you tired
of making the same old games?
Do you miss playing games in
the same room as your friends?
Today we're going
to talk about how
to create games utilizing
Google Cast interaction model
and bring multi-screen games
to the living room for all
to enjoy.
So what is a Google Cast game?
A Google Cast game enables
multi-screen gameplay
between mobile devices
and television,
whether it is for
one person or many,
you can bring
connected experiences
to the best screen in the house.
When you combine
the biggest screen
in the house with an
amazing controller,
great things can happen.
But in order to make
something truly great,
there are design nuances
for multi-screen gaming
which you need to
consider first.
First, make the game setup
with Google Cast fast and easy.
All Cast games should
utilize the Google Cast
SDK to discover
nearby cast devices
and automatically present the
user with the option to cast
as part of the game setup flow.
Next, you need to decide
whether the game is cast-enabled
or if the casting behavior
is required for gameplay.
Each option has slightly
different considerations
on how the players can
enter the cast flow
and whether they
can play this game
when they're away
from the television
or they need to
be in front of it.
If the game requires a Google
Cast endpoint in order to play,
make sure to explicitly
tell the players
and their first action should
be connect to the endpoint.
This will start a
receiver application
on an endpoint
like a Chromecast.
If the game is
cast-enabled, meaning
the game can be played without
a Google Cast endpoint,
you need to clearly
call out the capability
to cast the game session on
the main screen of the game
and provide a clear
user experience.
How are your devices in the
Google Cast endpoint going
to connect with each other?
There are several different
models that you can use,
but each one has
different implications.
First, let's talk about
how Cast applications work.
This is going to
get technical now.
Sender applications connect
to a receiver device
such as a Chromecast,
passing along
the application ID of the
receiver application to load.
The application is registered
via the Cast SDK developer
console.
The receiver device loads
a receiver application
from the cloud using a URL,
which has also been registered
from the Developer Console.
The application is
downloaded each time
it is launched by the sender.
The Cast SDK establishes
and maintains
a session between the receiver
application and the sender
application.
Sender applications
in this model
communicate with the receiver
application via the session
to implement a game
experience on the TV.
There are other models such
as a peer-to-peer model.
The peers connect
to one device which
acts as the host sender
and the host sender
maintains communication
with the receiver device
while updating the peers.
In this case, a companion
technology like Google Play
services real-time multiplayer
is an excellent choice
for peer-to-peer communication.
In the cloud-centric
model, a cloud service
manages most of the
game and player state
and keeps all clients in sync.
In this setup, both the
senders and the receiver
are clients of
the cloud service.
Here, Google Play game
services can also be used
for cloud-enabled API's.
So there's lots of different
ways to make a game.
All the games we released in
our game wave in November, 2014,
use the methods we just
covered to make great games.
Just like these games,
your real creative genius
shows itself when you combine
great social multiplayer
with the power of mobile
devices on the big screen.
Why?
Because mobile devices are
amazing game controllers,
believe it or not.
You can use touch, the
accelerometer, swipe,
selection, manipulation,
microphone,
sound, even the camera.
There's so many game
interactions you can create.
Why not explore and experiment?
Let's look at a spectrum
of game controls.
Abstract controls
interacts with the action
on the screen via some other
mechanism such as motion
or touch anywhere.
Virtual controls, are
somewhere in between,
touch something to control
something else on the screen.
Direct controls
occur when you touch
the thing you want to interact
with directly like an answer
on a trivia game.
When deciding on the
games input method,
consider the key
characteristics of the game.
What is the pace?
Is their public versus
private information?
Is there multiplayer?
Being aware of how these
characteristics will effect
gameplay will help
you make decisions
around your input mechanics.
For visual design, remember
not to fatigue the player
by making them constantly look
up and down at the screen.
Design the 10-foot experience
adhering to the TV design
guidelines and the 1-foot
experience adhering
to mobile guidelines
to understand
what to emphasize in the
relationship between the two.
When you do it all
right, you create
an entirely new living room
experience and players really
get involved with the game.
We've seen this happen with
several great Cast games
already and we want
yours to be next.
So how do you do that?
To get started, check
out the following links.
There are so many
unexplored games just
waiting to be created to inspire
and excite millions of gamers.
Please go make
something awesome.
That's it.
Thank you.
[GOOGLE THEME MUSIC]